- It's Mary Steenburgen
and Kelly Clarkson!
Give it up!
And that pie, girl that pie.
I took like three more bites
in the commercial break.
It was so dang good.
Being remote for most of the last year
has led to a few communication issues.
One happened this summer
when I was talking with
Bones and SEAL Team actor,
David Boreanaz, check it out.
- You can't hear me?
- I wish I, I can't hear you,
but I wish I could read lips, but I can't.
I'll put Louie down
- Okay, Navy Seal.
Navy, navy.
- No.
- Seal.
- This is like a game.
It sounds like shirt, okay.
- You play, you play.
- Yes, SEAL Team.
- Yes!
- Yes, SEAL Team!
(laughing)
- We edited it,
it was a lot longer.
(laughing)
So now in honor of one
of my favorite interviews
from the summer and of time on this show,
it's time to play the David
Boreanaz can't hear me game.
♪ The David Boreanaz can't hear me game ♪
(audience clapping)
(laughing)
That's a new one obviously.
All right, well, this is a,
this is a virtual version
of charades basically.
Here's how it works, Mary
and I will each take turns
trying to get the other to
say a certain word or phrase.
The catch is our
microphones will be on mute,
much like in the interview with David.
We each get 45 seconds to
get the other person to guess
as many words or phrases as possible.
We're allowed to say the words,
use motions and use props if you need
and whenever we want to pass,
look they gave us a pass card.
And if we're like, look,
we're not gonna make it,
we're going down.
So we have a pass card.
We each have eight words
the other person can guess
and if we can get a total of 10 correct
between the two of us,
everyone in our house seats
they're gonna win a fantastic prize.
So no pressure, Mary,
but don't suck.
(audience applauding)
Okay.
(laughing)
All right, let's do it!
Okay so mute my mic and I'll go first.
Ready and go!
(slow music)
- Guitar.
(dinging)
Music.
Waitress.
(dinging)
Serving.
Tea, drinking,
coffee, coffee cup,
mug.
(dinging)
Cup.
Game show,
set, flowers,
decorations
pass, pass, pass.
Daisy, pass.
Singing, you, amazing, genius.
Performer, song, song,
vocalizing,
loudly,
(buzzer dinging)
loudly.
- Oh (beep).
(laughing)
- What was that.
- That was my,
(laughing)
I didn't know how to do soprano.
So I'm sitting here
and you can't hear me
- Oh.
- and I'm like going
(screaming)
(laughing)
it was like.
I was trying to say sunflower, ah crap.
Okay, here we go.
All right.
You did really well, I wasn't great.
Okay.
So Mary's turn.
We need seven right to win a prize
for everyone in our house seats.
I feel like we're gonna nail it.
I feel like we can do it.
So mute Mary's mic for me,
mute Mary's mic, say that five times fast.
Okay.
Okay, ready and go!
- Okay.
- Where'd she go?
Where'd she go?
Oh, accordion!
(dinging)
Accordion!
(slow music)
Smell,
smell, soup, smell, soup.
Pass, pass!
Trophy,
a trophy.
I can't see it.
I can't see it in that screen.
Critic's Choice Award?
I don't know which one
it is, I can't see it.
I can't see it.
It wasn't going in the,
globe, Golden Globes!
(dinging)
Oh!
(screaming)
Oh, Ted Danson!
Husband!
(audience applauding)
(laughing)
(clapping)
- It was supposed to be handsome.
- Oh, I was like, well that one too.
(laughing)
- Wait, I really,
I really want your audience to get that
and I'm scared they didn't.
- Well, here's the thing,
I kind of run the show
and it's been a really,
you know, crappy 2020.
So they're basically, they're
gonna get presents anyway.
- Good.
- We failed,
but we didn't fail them.
Everyone is a winner today.
All right y'all with the
OXO Eight Cup Coffee Maker
you can easily brew a
better tasting full carafe
or one cup with the touch of a button
and the OXO Conical Burr Coffee Grinder
unlocks your beans full potential.
Combined you get
delicious java every time.
You're all getting the
coffee maker and grinder.
(audience cheering)
All right, thank you so
much for playing, Mary.
Next time we're gonna nail it.
I feel it in my bones.
- Next time.
- I love you so much, thank
you for coming back on my show.
I really think you are super rad.
- Well, I have a,
I have a new dream and that's,
that I'm gonna write something
you sing one of these days.
- Yes!
Make it depressing!
Let's do it, okay.